I don't know how you guys do it because
you all wear these superhero costumes as
a part of your living and I put one on
for a four-minute segment earlier in the
show and I was showing you backstage I
have just completely sweats through my
entire shirt I found it almost
unbearable
thanks for getting a close-up of that
that's what America the heart attack I
really don't know how you guys do it
being in those suits is absolutely
incredible there are two seasons to
being in a suit right there's the
absolutely hot under boob sweat season
yeah and then there's the the sweat
freezes because it's cold out and you're
cold the entire night season right so
there's no there's no in-between there
is no middle ground when you tweet it
out of you first of all your costume
changed so what happened tell us how
your costume changed we made it a little
bit more utilitarian considering that we
shoot in the Pacific Northwest right so
much you wear a fleece shirt now I've
seen on the show you're right right
before you wear please how we're
Birkenstocks yeah yeah and green arrow
you gotta get this out I've got a
knapsack full of locally sourced veggies
yeah you are you're obviously you're an
amazing shape you tweeted out a photo
that I think that we have right here
there you are yeah I have to put on a
40-pound suit to get anything that looks
like that so congratulations I just told
Stephen I wouldn't wear a t-shirt on
camera with them
you